this year's Nobel Prize in Chemistry is
about tailoring proteins for the
benefits of humans and our planet
proteins are best friends they were
everywhere inside us they helped us move
and see think to the left you see an
enzyme that is a protein that can speed
up chemical reactions by your catalyst
to the right you see an antibody that is
a protein that I can grab onto foreign
objects and protect us from invaders
this year's laureates harnessed the
power evolution to make even better
proteins that can be used to catalyze
chemical reactions in a sustainable way
and to treat diseases they developed
methods that combine advanced knowledge
about how proteins work with a bit of
good luck to be able to find improved
variants beyond what we may guess that's
a very smart trick it takes the best of
what we know and ask the experiment to
tell us even more this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry unifies two aspects
of protein evolution one half goes to
Francis Arnold for the directed
evolution of enzymes and one half goes
to George Smith and Gregory winter for
the phase display of peptides and
antibodies here we will now first learn
about fates display George Smith was
born 1941 in Norwalk United States for
his college education he took a very
wise decision and went to have afford
College a warm and nice liberal arts
college in Pennsylvania he then went to
Harvard for his ph.d
Cambridge United States the other
Cambridge as we call it in Europe he is
now an emeritus professor at the
University of Missouri your Smith
develop face display this is an
ingenious method that provides a
physical link between genotype and
phenotype what's inside and outside the
method has become extremely useful for
deriving knowledge about binding
determinants to derive better binding
proteins and also to improve proteins in
many other ways including stability
towards my phone I welcome you onto
stage we are very much looking forward
to hearing your lecture
[Applause]
[Music]
when this award was announced on October
3 my friends who were actual chemists
were surprised to learn that I was one
too
and that brings up the question of what
is a chemist of course we might try to
use anecdotal evidence to recognize
chemists by their behavior for example
two chemists are toiling away in the lab
when a funeral procession approaches on
the road below and chemist one stands at
the window with this hand over his heart
until the funeral progression of
procession has passed and afterward
chemist who says I am in awe of the
reverence that you show to the dead and
chemist one says well she was a darn
good wife my darn good wife Margie Sabol
is very much alive and sitting in the
audience as
[Applause]
[Music]
as our our Don gher darn good sons are
darn good daughter-in-law my darn good
brother and sister-in-law my darn good
sister and brother-in-law and some darn
good colleagues some of whom will figure
in this lecture because they were
directly involved in the experiments
that I'm about to describe and by the
way in case you have seen the movie the
wife I would like to assure you that
Margie didn't invent phage display
actually I think it may be a little
doubtful that phage display was an
invention I I know that it looks like
that from the outside but from the
inside from my point of view phage
display was a series of small
incremental advances from the knowledge
that I had the ideas the published
findings and so on that my science
community had made available to me and
that are the nutrients of my science
community so my science community is the
global overlapping community of
molecular biologists of evolutionary
biologists of immunologist protein
chemists
biologists it etc so I feel that I'm
accepting this award as a representative
of my science community and I say my
science community because I belong to
the community not because the community
belongs to me and so perhaps a better
way is to say that it's our science
community and it's our science community
in a broader sense as well because the
society as a whole the in so many myriad
ways sustains our science communities
including mine the school's educate our
children some of whom go on to be a
the professional members of science
communities they go to our universities
for their continuing education including
my University the University of Missouri
that not only educate our our children
but also sustain our local science
communities and also our national
institutions such as the National
Academy of Sciences the National Science
Foundation the National Institutes of
Health in the United States the Medical
Research Council in in Great Britain
that that promotes science that do some
science themselves and that's that
support science fiscally so let me
introduce phages phages are viruses that
infect bacteria this is the phage the
class of phage that phage display was
developed with they're called
filamentous phage because of their shape
long and thin like a filament phages in
general have many different shapes but
they have this in common that they have
an outer coat an outer coat of protein
made up of phage coat proteins and that
coat surrounds or in cases the phage
genome the phage chromosome that has the
phage genes and the particles are about
one micrometer long that's about half
the length of the cells they infect but
only six nanometers in diameter so they
are extremely thin compared to their
length I've mentioned chromosomes genes
and proteins and let's just be clear
give you a crash course in molecular
biology let's be clear the relationship
among them so the DNA chromosome is a
long chain of the four nucleotides a G C
and T in a specific order or sequence
and a gene is a segment of that
chromosome that specifies or encodes as
we say it a polypeptide so a polypeptide
is a long chain of the 20 natural amino
acids again in a specific order or
sequence that is specified by the gene
and polypeptides in general will fold
spontaneously into their natural
three-dimensional shape their nades
that's the native protein that has the
proteins biological activity I would
like to introduce one more term that
will appear and that's peptide so a
peptide is a short chain of amino acids
and in the context of this lecture
peptides are encoded by short segments
of DNA in genes back to phage I would
like to briefly outline the phage
infection cycle very simplified and I'm
drawing the phage about 3 times bigger
than its normal than its size relative
to the bacterial cell that it infects so
the first stage is attachment of the
phage to the cell that it's going to
affect and within minutes the phage
chromosome is intruded into the interior
of the cell without killing the cell and
over the course of the next hour or so
the phage chromosome replicates so now
there's many chromosomes inside the cell
and the phage proteins that are
specified by the phage genes including
the coat proteins coat proteins
accumulate in the cell and ultimately
the cell extrudes progeny viruses
progeny phages in great numbers perhaps
a hundred within the first hour
filamentous phage are a little unusual
among phage in general in that they
don't kill the cell they in fact so the
infected cell continues to grow and
divide although at a lower rate than
uninfected cells and continues to
extrude progeny phage meanwhile these
progeny phage are able to
in fact any uninfected cells in the
culture and so soon all the cells are
infected so let me outline what this
means in numbers so if we start with a
flask with one liter of culture and
about say 10 10 to the 11th cells and
one phage particle and shake that
vigorously overnight we end up with the
next day with about 50 times more cells
and about 10 to the 15th phages so 10 to
the 15 some of you may not be familiar
with that number so 10 to the 6 is a
million 10 to the 9 is a billion 10 to
the 12th is it is a trillion and 10 to
the 15th is a thousand trillion or a
gazillion and and that's and this is a
tremendously tremendous advantage of
phages
as study organism because they can
produce they can be produced in enormous
numbers very cheaply and very simply so
faint display so I've done with phage
now and we're getting getting onto phage
display phage display had its origin at
the end of my sabbatical leave with Bob
Webster in the biochemistry department
at Duke University Bob this is a picture
of Bob recently cleaning up after
hurricane Florence earlier this year at
this retirement home on the North
Carolina coast but he was a major
investigator of the biology of
filamentous phage and I was a newcomer
to the field and that's why I came to
his lab for for the for my sabbatical
and much of my research was focused on a
particular coke protein gene the Koch
protein encoded by that Koch protein
gene was at the tip of the virus the tip
of the phage particle
it's a multifunctional protein
part of it is buried in the particle
innocent is is essential to the
structural integrity of the particle but
the rest of it is exposed out in out to
the surrounding medium and plays
critical roles in the infection process
and it was also known through many
channels that this protein was flexing
the exposed parts were flexible that
they could be manipulated that they
didn't have a set tight structure and
that suggested to me at the time that it
might be possible possible to insert
foreign pieces of DNA into this coat
protein gene and into the part of it
that coded for the parts of the protein
that are exposed on the surface and as a
result the extra peptide it would make a
longer gene encoding not only the
regular coat protein but also a little
extra piece and that extra piece of the
protein the peptide that that extra
piece corresponds to would be displayed
on the surface so down the hall from Bob
Webster's lab was Paul motor cheese lab
here he is getting his chemistry Nobel
Prize three years ago and he was
studying a protein called eco r1 at the
time and he gave me the gene for eco r1
an antibody against the eco r1 protein
so here's what I did with it I cut out a
piece of the equal are one gene and
inserted it into that coat protein gene
and the expectation was that the
resulting construct the resulting
modified phage would have a piece of the
eco r1 protein of pep talk from eco r1
protein encoded by that piece of eco r1
gene on its surface at the tip so this
is the first phage days display
construct
and I should say that from now on in the
lecture I'm going to simplify the
cartoon representing phage display
constructs so I'm going to eliminate
representing the chromosome and the host
coke protein gene and just have a
colored rectangle representing the
foreign DNA insert that's in that Co
protein gene well I told you that that
Paul mode which gave me the antibody
against that protein so I should say
that this construct this phage was still
infective but when I mix it with the
antibody against equal our one protein
it blocked infection presumably because
it bound to that piece of eco run
protein on the surface and prevented an
infection and this is the first
indication that the phage display
concept seemed to be feasible it seemed
that it was possible to display foreign
pieces and foreign proteins or pieces of
proteins peptides on the surface of
phage I was very excited about this and
it's very likely that many of you don't
understand what was interesting about
that and so please wait I will try to
make it clear but I was really
interested in so when a week or so later
when Margie and I drove back home to
Missouri I soon swung my research
program over to developing the phage
display idea and luckily a darn good
colleague Steve Parmley showed up as a
graduate student in the lab and Steve
had two projects one project was to
develop a really practical phage display
vector a vector that would make it easy
to insert foreign pieces of DNA into the
coq protein gene having minimal effect
on the on the function of the phage that
have still be infective still be able to
be produced and that wasn't an easy
project yet he tried many there were
many tries some of which didn't work out
so well so one of them was Pig 3c
big three seed didn't work too well at
least it was certainly wasn't the best
construct but it soon became a mascot in
the lab and Steve was gonna take this
over to the Nobel Museum as one of our
artifacts and this and this the the
second task that Steve took on was
developing affinity selection and I know
those words don't mean anything to most
people in this audience and that will be
explained presently so just as Steve
left the lab another darn good colleague
Jamie Scott came as a postdoc and Jamie
Scott was the first one to make a large
random peptide library and I'm gonna
describe that in a minute too
and to use Steve's affinity selection
process also to be described presently
to select peptide from that library and
I would just like to mention a third
darn good colleague that's Robert Davis
Robert Davis came to my lab just about
the same time as Jamie as the chief
manager and technician and he was a
wonderful and wonderfully productive
technician with just marvelous
intuitive lab sense and he had many
tasks and one of them was that he was
our DNA core so what it meant in those
days that he's responsible for all the
DNA sequencing in our lab we calculate
conservative conservatively that he
sequenced a million bases of DNA using
the old-fashioned radioactive technology
and if you've ever used that some of you
are old enough to abuse that you know
how laborious Lee how laborious that is
and how technically demanding it is so I
hope Jamie will forgive me for
not using the work that she published in
1990 as the illustration of random
peptide libraries and affinity selection
I'm going to use a work that involved a
model system that came to our lab a few
years after she left because I think
it's easier to explain so this this was
the S protein system that was brought to
our lab by two graduate students from
Yale John Ladd Barry and David Schultz
and it's the S protein system so the S
protein system derives from research of
Fred Richards at Yale in the late 1950s
he was studying the structure of the
enzyme Ryba nucleus which is represented
here in three dimensional form and he
showed that the proteolytic enzyme
subtle eyesand would split ribonuclease
into two pieces one piece was the s
peptide that was only 20 amino acids
long and the other piece was the S
protein which is a hundred and four
amino acids long and those two pieces
could be separated from each other and
when you did that
neither piece had the enzyme activity of
ribonuclease but when you added s
peptide back to s protein it bound to s
protein and restored enzyme activity
this is the S protein system and we
regarded it s protein as kind of a like
a stand-in for a receptor maybe a
receptor involved in a disease or
something is kind of like a pretend
receptor because it was we could even
buy it commercially and maybe we could
think of s peptide as the natural ligand
for that receptor say a hormone or
something and maybe when that hormone is
overproduce and it binds to the receptor
you get the dreaded s protein disease
and let me assure you this is fake news
this is just pretend but this is the way
we thought of this as a model system so
I'm just to introduce a random peptide
libraries and affinity selection
in the context of an experiment was done
in the middle 90s by jinan you in my
laboratory as a graduate student in my
laboratory so she had this s protein
receptor which he could get in pure form
and she also had a random peptide
library so let me describe what that is
a random peptide library is a huge
collection of phage clones and each
clone differs with regard to the hoops
with regard to the foreign DNA insert
that's inserted into the Koch protein
and these are short DNA inserts and the
particular library they that she used
had inserts or were long enough to
encode 15 amino acids and they were
random DNA sequences and as a result
random 15 amino acid peptides are
displayed on the surface of the phage at
the tip round blue peptides sharp gold
peptides squared green peptides etc and
actually her library had 250 million
different clones and I assure you that
the random DNA inserts didn't have to be
synthesized one at a time that would be
an impossible task they could all be
synthesized together in a single vesicle
in one operation and also they didn't
have to be inserted into the Koch
protein gene a one by one that all this
insertions could be again be
accomplished in a single vessel in a
single operation so here's a picture of
the library in that bottle there are 10
to the 15th pages representing 250
million different phage clones each one
displaying a different 15 random 15
amino acid peptide so here was her task
her task was to find out of that 250
million peptides
very rare peptides that would happen to
have the ability to bind to that
receptor to that s protein receptor you
can see this would be a
really hard tasks how are you gonna go
through 250 million
phages one at a time especially as
they're all mixed together but you
didn't have to do that because of the
affinity selection procedure that that
Steve had previously worked out so let
me describe a Finity selection first the
receptor was immobilized on a solid
surface it was the plastic surface of an
ordinary plastic petri dish next the
library or a portion of it representing
every one of the Clones many times over
was poured into the petri dish and
sloshed around for an hour or so
and during that sloshing around period
if there was a peptide that had good
affinity for the immobilized receptor
the peptide and it and the phage that it
was attached to would be captured on the
surface of the petri dish whereas all
the other phages the vast majority in
the library would be floating free and
that allowed those floating free those
unbound phage particles to be washed
away leaving just the particles you want
and they could be released and you're
home free but you're not because the
released particles were released in tiny
tiny numbers so there are two reasons
for that
one is that any phage clone that
displayed happen to display a peptide
with high affinity for the receptor
would be a tiny minority of all the
original phage clones there and
furthermore the the capture processes
not very far from 100% efficient maybe
more like 1% of efficient if you're
lucky but it doesn't matter because
remember that these particles are
infectious by simply by infecting fresh
bacterial cells you can produce them you
can amplify them up to trillions or
gazillions so this is the peptide using
the one letter abbreviation for the
amino acids that
that jinan selected in her experiment
and although I just say it's very
important to point out that never did we
use any information about s peptide in
either the synthesis of the library the
construction of the library which was
done by collaborators in Japan who made
the library available to us and
certainly had didn't have s peptide or s
protein in mind and nor Nord wasn't used
in the finiti selection nevertheless I
think it's it's instructive to compare
the sequence of the selected peptide
with a sequence of s protein the
so-called natural ligand well they match
in five positions and four of them are
very important the ones in red because
they happen that happens to be matches
in precisely the four amino acids of s
peptide that were known structurally to
be deeply buried in s protein when s
peptide binds s protein so these are the
residues of s peptide that are
responsible for the tight binding and
the selected peptide matches them so in
a certain sense this is really kind of a
successful experiment and I I think I've
explained enough about it
I just want to make a generalization
that this artificial selection in the
petri dish mimics in some important
respects natural evolution in the living
world natural evolution depends
critically on diversification generating
varieties of a variance of living things
and the and in phage display what
corresponds to that is making enormous
phage display libraries with great
diversity of peptides displayed secondly
evolution depends on natural selection
to favor some variants and disfavor
others and so to in phage display
affinity selection greatly favors some
peptides over
on the basis of their affinity so it
this is a very simplified kind of
selection that the experimenter controls
and decides for the experimenters own
needs and this diversification and
natural selection is the engine of
adaptation in a natural in in the
natural world evolution in the living
world and so generation of great
diversity and affinity selection leads
to peptides with desired activities so
let me summarize this again is the
library and by applying her specific
selection protocol to that library she
was able to discover in that library a
cure for s for the imaginary s protein
disease but what end would there be two
other Marvel's that could be selected
from the same library using other
selection protocols what Marvel won
Marvel - who knows what what end there
is to this and indeed several other
members of our science community have
filled bottles like this numerous
bottles like this with other phase
display libraries of novel and
imaginative design and from those
libraries some remarkable marbles have
been selected some of which you'll hear
about from one of my co laureates and
our next speaker Greg winter thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you